good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday it's a
gorgeous day in New York it is and we
have a 20
29. wow just going right into the ageism
because you are a new woman today than
you were last we saw you on the toast
you have officially
grounded you have officially turned 18.
I've turned 18. I'm so excited for what
this year will bring me you know I could
buy a pack of cigarettes cigarettes I
could enlist should I
I think you should I think that's really
what I need I mean I do think like they
would throw you overboard uh the way I
wouldn't last 10 minutes in the Army
mm-hmm first because I would just annoy
the [__] out of everyone I'd look for
like a community of like you know fellow
Army goers who like love show tunes and
the Kardashians and everyone would find
me annoying and then like the first day
I have to wake up what like 4am you
would not stop complaining oh my God
endlessly that was like one of my
nightmares growing up like being sent to
military school you know I don't know
why like ever I feel like our generation
maybe was Cadet Kelly like that was like
the punishment like if she was bad she's
gonna go to military that's just like
kids no I feel like it was very much
like a 90s early 2000s thing like
because of Cadet Kelly not because of
Cadet Kelly but I feel like now there's
other things that they're like if she's
bad she's gonna right and then it was
like those Provo Canyon type schools
yeah what are the kids scared of these
days
me neither I think that's the problem
with this generation there's no like
looming threat no not me turning 29 and
like talking about the kids you know
that's what happens that's what happens
so we are back in studio I took
yesterday off even though uh we recorded
actually for yesterday
um in lieu of a toast episode there was
a patreon podcast that was probably one
of my favorite ones ever because why was
it your favorite one because it was all
about me it was all about turdy everyone
submitted the most random topics and we
ventured to see if turdy could make it
about her and you know what she made
mostly everything about her but there
were a few things that she was stumped
what did I get stumped on Alaska Alaska
I couldn't make it about myself Aldi
Supermarket never been to one and like
the Spanish War but we've never heard of
it but then we decided that way that one
wasn't there we found a way the thing is
it was a great episode so if you're a
patreon member you heard from us
yesterday but if you're just a regular
toaster we haven't seen you in quite a
bit hope everybody hope everybody had a
great weekend how was your weekend it
was amazing celebrated my birthday on
Saturday with you know friends yesterday
big family day it was really an amazing
birthday like I there's no post birthday
Blues here like I feel so I feel like
that's how you should feel after like a
good birthday like so grateful such
wonderful people in my life everybody
wrote me such beautiful cards really
Jackie I read the card one more time
before I went to bed it was hands down
the best written card I've ever gotten
in my life like well and that says a lot
that actually doesn't say too much
because you don't really like write
cards for people I didn't say it was the
best card I'd ever written no no no I
don't like to write cards no you didn't
let me finish myself maybe if you let me
finish my second because it sounded like
an insult no okay I said because you
don't really write emotional cards for
people people don't write the most
emotional card to you because they know
it's like not that important to you you
give what you get yeah like there are
some people in the family who are known
for one like Olivia writing emotional
cards and also loving emotional cards
and like that's just not for you in
general so that's why I feel like you
don't get always like
the most emotional card but I was like I
don't care what this [__] wants like I
have a lot to say to her it's what this
[__] needs I have a lot to say to her
and I'm gonna say it you know let's talk
about my reputation when it comes to
cards in the family because I have
something cards are really important in
our family so are gifts but like cards
you better be saying something and
everyone like jokes like I will watch
the person reading it where like it was
at a tear was that it's a competition
it's a competition for sure you cry so
everyone knows I'm like the loser in
that competition like I write the worst
cards and like it's like a joke like
Claudia doesn't even try blah blah
sometimes you don't even write a card
somehow okay that was okay there was
like five years ago where like I didn't
write anyone a card for like a year it
was like last year no it was really it
was it was recently you decided like you
are who you are and you're not raiding
cards Jackie I swear to God that was
like years ago I promise but wait let me
get to myself it was three to four
months check up let me get to my party
my point is like I have this reputation
and I think it's high time everybody
knows like I have a reputation sure but
when I sit down to write someone a card
like I really like I'm writing like from
the heart like I'm like trying really
hard and then like everybody's like oh
that's the best you got like I'm not
it's not for lack of trying which makes
it really sad I feel the same same way
for me my cards are always like pretty
middle of the line I'm never the well
sometimes I'm the best if I have a lot
to say but I'm I'm never like the
standout card writer but I'm telling you
when I sit down to write it like there's
not a false word on the page no and like
I tear up yeah no I agree and also
what's so frustrating is so many like
cliched sentences like I mean with every
fiber of my being they ring true but
they sound corny right it's like you're
the most amazing sister like I am like I
mean that when I say that I feel that
100 the writing cards is really hard it
is Olivia is like the best she's we call
her like the Hallmark but girly but I
just want to say like just because I
think when we all open cards we judge
them based on their length correct no
not necessarily but of course like if
it's really long it's like wow this
person really tried and I just don't
like fully agree with that I don't think
that's what it is okay I feel like
everyone's cards are pretty much the
same length of like the two pages one
and a half yeah the card yeah I just I
find writing cards like really hard I do
too but it's always like fun when you
have something to say like yesterday I
had something to say so I didn't dread
it well it was beautiful it was an
amazing day so many well wishes from you
know celebrities in my DMs which is
really all you really wanted that's why
I went to bed with a big smile on my
face that's why you're okay with your
birthday yeah yeah for sure no and I
really am okay with my birthday like I
don't I don't really mind my age like I
like the way you know I like where I'm
at in my life my career I love the way
that I look like I'm okay that's great I
do think we're gonna need to have a
crisis counselor next year last year no
seriously
Hide Your Kids yeah we'll find the best
the best there is crisis life coach I'm
sure there's someone who specializes I
just feel like we shouldn't even talk
about it you know yeah and a Year's a
really long time so much can happen long
so much can happen it's so long
yeah
it's just not I'm glad you had a great
birthday that was what we endeavored it
was really great for you because of you
and all my family everybody made it so
special I got great gifts great curds
great photos posted to me on Instagram
true what else could you ask for my
birthday honestly
so true right yeah we had a good time so
now that that's behind us we're looking
forward we are we've got a great show
today we haven't been in studio in a bit
Thursday since Thursday
yeah yeah we didn't come in on Friday
Thursday so we've got lots to do you
know what's what's new with you Jax oh
Lots new with me I've been celebrating
my sister's birthday so that took up a
lot of my time but I'm so excited
because I am doing something really
exciting tomorrow that I haven't shared
on the podcast but I shared on my
Instagram I'm doing talk shop live
tomorrow which is like live shopping
Like Home shopping Vibes but it's all
online so the link is in my bio when
it's on my stories and I'll keep sharing
it until tomorrow but it's tomorrow
night at 7 p.m eastern time I will be
going live selling signed copies of my
book for pre-order the camper and the
counselor so that is right now the only
place where you could get a signed copy
and also the live stream's gonna be so
much fun we're gonna be in studio I'm
gonna have some special guests yeah like
I don't want to spoil anything but like
big celebrities dropping by big
celebrity shopping by and that's kind of
all the information you're gonna get
yeah it's gonna be a really fun stream
so again the link will be in available
anywhere I post links and we're gonna
have a great time so I'm really excited
about that oh it's also Prime day I know
I'm overwhelmed already I know last year
I got my Kindle like it was such a good
purchase I got the Kindle Oasis which is
on sale today if anybody's looking for
one
um I get so overwhelmed with prime day
and then I just I always [__] it up I
always just like get nothing I think
last year I got like pickleball rackets
actually it's actually pretty good
that's a pretty good our pickleball rack
it's like expensive like good ones
um they vary but I've not seen like the
a good one is not crazy crazy no it's a
good tennis racket it's like a million
dollars yeah and they're like custom
right I mean they'll get one with my
name on it like your tennis chocolate
has to be like fitted for your height
and your size right and The Pickle bar
Rockets you can just get like a nice one
on Amazon oh that's a good one they're
one size fits all I feel like people are
always getting vacuums on Prime day oh
do I need a vacuum no but I saw a while
ago a real of like someone power washing
their shower with like a power washer
was it like a steam mop or like a power
washer
like neither it was like a long stick
with like a round brush at the end yeah
yeah I see those on Tick Tock and I just
feel like I need one but I don't want to
I probably won't get anything this Prime
day because I'm not gonna like send it
all to Florida right I don't need it
right now and like I just don't need
those things right now so I might have
to sit this Prime day out damn unless
it's something that I could like use
right now but I have
oh my God his Kindle's always reminding
me because I've been switching back and
forth on my can like reading Kindles
depending if I'm out I use my small one
if I'm home I use my big one and they're
like do you want to go back to the place
from Jacqueline's fourth Kindle I'm like
damn why do you have to say it like that
it was it was getting rude it's getting
rude it's like when you get air pods
it's like Jacqueline's fifth airpods
it's like okay we don't have to count
yeah no that's weird it's rude yeah I
agree 100 and I know where all four
Kindles are by the way and I use three
of them one of them is defunct like it's
done don't I have one of yours I think I
got it back at one point no it's still
my house I used it the other day oh
really yeah huh you honestly you just
never have enough Kindles yeah
so I just felt like that was shady that
is Shady maybe come up with another name
for it like Jaclyn's big Kindle
Jacqueline little Kindle Jackie's like
cutest little first exciting Kindle like
Jackie's first born the Kindle that made
Jackie fell in love with Kindles the
Kindle that made Jackie who she is yeah
it's so true
um so there's lots of news there is you
know because weekend was big it was I
think I got everything the top five
we've got Ruthie we do we've got sex
lives of college girls which I really
need to get into we have
the flip heard around the world
the flip oh my God we have intended
episodes since the flip okay so I feel
like we should just like dive in
honestly you're ready here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
and it's Wife Swap oh my God Wife Swap
sorry do it again without further Ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know
oh my God not me like being out of
control I'm so sorry no it's okay I took
a day off and I forgot who I was like
you know
all right well today's episode
is brought to you by honey today's
episode is sponsored by PayPal honey the
easy way to save money when shopping on
your iPhone or computer it only takes a
few seconds to download honey and that
means if you go to add it to your laptop
or iPhone right now you could be done
before this ad is even over and you know
what else Works fast Honey's deal
finding abilities it is a free shopping
tool that scours the internet for promo
codes applies the best ones it finds to
your cart and really just saves the day
every time here's how it works imagine
you're shopping at one of your favorite
sites on the internet you check out the
honey button will appear and all you
have to do is Click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons that it can find for that
website and if they find a working
coupon you will just watch the prices
drop I have saved money on clothes on
makeup on food Electronics like pretty
much every time I shop online I like
forget Honey's even there and then that
little dancing coin comes up he's like
hey turdy want to save some money I
click apply coupons seconds later I'm a
free woman and I've saved money and I
feel better about it so honey also now
doesn't even just work on desktops it
also works on your iPhone you can
activate it under the Safari app on your
phone and you can save money on the go
I'm always shopping online now because I
love using app pay so honey is just kind
of doing the most for everyone at all
times of day getting honey seriously
only takes a few seconds by getting it
you're doing yourself a solid and you're
sporting the toast get PayPal honey for
free when you go to joinhoney.com toast
that's join honey
j-o-i-n-honey
h-o-n-e-y.com slash toast joinhoney.com
toast there's really no reason I'm not
gonna sit here and explain it to you
like you guys are stupid like it's
really obvious just do it today's
episode is also brought to you by liquid
IV the number one powered hydration
brand in America and it's now available
in sugar-free it's years in the making
the hydration multiplier sugar-free
version uses a proprietary zero sugar
hydration solution with no artificial
sweeteners with three times the
electrolytes of the leading sports drink
plus eight vitamins and nutrients for
everyday Wellness liquid IV hydrates two
times faster than water alone keep your
daily routine exciting with three new
flavors white peach green grape and
lemon lime if you know and love liquid
IV then definitely check out their zero
sugar um hydration solution it's
fabulous it's amazing for hangovers and
migraines or fatigue exhaustion
dehydration whatever reasons remember
like a bad time to be hydrated you know
but it's so hard it's so hard to keep up
with hydration I literally like was
going to bed yesterday and I was like oh
my God
I haven't drank one sip of water today
like it was so crazy so it could just
get away from you and hydration
multiplier from liquid IV is always
there for you
you pour one stick of liquid IV into 16
ounces of water and it'll hydrate you
two times faster and more efficiently
than water alone the result of an
extensive research and development
process to perfect the flavor and
efficacy liquid IV combines signs back
to zero sugar technology with the
Brand's commitment to delicious real
flavors it's non-GMO and it's free from
gluten dairy and soy it has no
artificial sweeteners and zero sugar
they also are partnering with leading
organizations to fun and Foster
innovative solutions that help
communities protect both their water and
their Futures real people real flavor
real hydration now sugar-free grab
liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free in bulk nationwide at Costco
or get 20 off when you go to liquid
iv.com and use co-host at checkout
that's 20 off anything you order when
you use promo code toast at liquid
ivy.com thank you Claudia and welcome
you know what we should get for Prime
day some big fans because this summer
The Summer's hot and The Summer's not
going to be going our way I like that we
have to sit here like this yeah I like
that I can never have enough like fans
in my house I'm wearing shorts today it
makes no difference oh my fan just died
that's terrible I have a mini fan but
our Spirits did not oh wait the fan is
on
and it died okay cool better your
spirits than that this speaker died the
speaker died but our Spirits did not
know myself when my fan dies at my
spirit dies yeah well it's a little
early in the show for your spirit to die
so okay it's back she's alive she's
alive our first story is a journey
Jonah Hill's ex Sarah Brady claims he
was emotionally abusive she says it's
been a year of healing so over the past
I would say five days Jonah Hill's ex
Sarah Brady who he broke up with like
about a year ago
um and then he started dating someone
more recently that we reported on and
they just had a baby together but she's
speaking out about their relationship
and alleging that the actor was quote
emotionally abusive during their time
together in a series of Instagram story
posts made between Friday and Saturday
the surf instructor shared multiple
screenshots of various alleged text
message exchanges between herself and
the 39 year old actor she said quote
this is a warning to all girls if your
partner is talking to you like this make
an Exit Plan call me if you need an ear
she showed the text message is from
Jonah it's alleged from Jonah but
they're from Jonah asking her to take
down any surfing photos from her
Instagram with her quote ass in a thong
after she deleted all the posts he told
her allegedly it was a good start but
didn't seem to get his point she shared
a lot of screenshots one that's going
very viral is him saying this it's like
a list right he said plain and simple if
you need surfing with men boundaryless
inappropriate friendships with men to
model to post pictures of yourself in a
bathing suit to post sexual pictures
friendships with women who are in
unstable places and from your wild
recent past Beyond getting a lunch or
coffee or something respectful and I am
not the right partner for you if these
things bring you to a place of happiness
I support it and there will be no hard
feelings these are my boundaries for a
romantic partnership my boundaries with
you based on the ways these actions have
hurt are trust by the way not him being
like so crazy but like kind of
respectful about it like do you know
what I mean right no he's like setting
boundaries which is you know a
thing you should do people should do and
it's very encouraging okay maybe his
boundaries are not what you know
your boundaries would be or even
something that you would that would work
for you in a relationship but like it's
he's trying to like speak his truth his
his truth also so the ex-girlfriend has
been posting a lot of screenshots and
also like a lot of um
like you know using
big words she said he's uh misogynist
I think narcissists
um
what else emotional abuser emotional
abuser which we have and so she's
sharing a lot of the screenshots with
like are not flattering for Jonah and
people are like Jonah Hill is canceled
so when I saw this I immediately thought
of the conversation we had a mere few
weeks ago how about and you brought up
how he has this like fetish for normies
yeah like he's always dating someone who
is a complete normal person like he's
never dated a fellow celebrity like it's
always a normal Normie and knowing that
he has these like you know crazy
boundaries and like is looking for a
very specific type of partner it
actually makes a lot of sense why he's
you know in the Normie pool because him
being a celebrity and like a wealthy
person puts him in a position of power
and he clearly you know has these rules
that he wants his Partners to follow so
it immediately made me think of that and
of course it made me think of Ruthie of
course well everyone it pertains to the
toast Justice for Ruthie of course
because this is not a man that I
personally would want to be in a
relationship with but my thoughts about
the story have have ebbdened load
throughout the weekend because I feel
like when I first saw when I first saw
that this was making headlines that she
was like posting the screenshots and
stuff and I hadn't read them yet I was
like that's kind of like weird to post
like your boyfriend's personal personal
text messages and I think some people
are also like taking issue with that
it's not like he like said this in any
public forum because everyone is
recently talking about Keke Palmer's man
who said pretty much the same thing in
his own way publicly public publicly on
Twitter which was like yikes yeah so and
this is like when you're in a
relationship with someone like you hope
that you can text them and like that
that's stays private stays private so
then I read the text messages and I was
like woof like these are yikesville
yikesville and by the way I personally
like don't like Jonah Hill I don't I
don't understand I don't stand I don't
like dislike him but I don't like him so
I really don't have a horse in this race
like if he goes down like not your
problem not my problem no you will not
lose sleep but then I was reading the
text message and I was like oh like
these are really intense and like that's
kind of crazy especially like he messed
I think he found her on Instagram
through her surfing photos and but he
like joined the surfer like a crew right
and he like dm'd one of her photos to
her with like heart eyes and then like
those are the exact type of photos that
he wants taken down now that they're in
a relationship so it's like a little
hypocritical I'm like this is not good
for Mr Hill but then an Instagram
account that I follow called House
inhabit she posts like such like long
she like takes care to stop provoking
stop like she just always has a take on
something and it's always just
interesting and different from whatever
the like mainstream line of thinking so
I'm just like oh okay I was watching and
I guess she like knows the surfer
community that you've discussed and she
was saying how um this actually started
like a year ago when Jonah got into the
relationship with the new girl this ex
Sarah Brady started posting like old
texts to them and her what she was
saying was like oh well you were just
like texting me five weeks ago and now
you're in a relationship and like she's
been kind of like trying to expose him
for the last year and like changed her
tune to all of this recently and like
it's also now that he's just had a baby
like right it's the timing is kind of
weird and I would encourage if you'd
like want to know more about the
situation to just watch her highlight on
Jonah Hill house and have it because it
was just more context to the situation
um and now I'm just like questioning and
the Sarah Brady did post about this but
like why she would post all this now
like he literally just had a baby yeah
and these texts have been in existence
for over a year right but she said
um this is what she said about the baby
thing because I think people were like
asking one more question she said that
she waited until his partner gave birth
before she released the screenshots of
aggressive text messages quote I didn't
want her to have to see all of this
while she was pregnant because I didn't
know what kind of stress that would
cause her and her baby physically she
also admitted that while the timing can
seem bad she hoped that um Olivia Millar
the girl uh saw the post so she could
make an informed decision of how she
wants to care for herself and her baby
yikes
yeah I mean again I agree with your
sentiment I don't have a particularly
strong positive or negative feeling
about Jonah Hill like I like some of his
work I see my favorite celebrity no
um
and I find what I find most interesting
about this whole situation is like what
was it literally a year ago where like
Jonah Hill did this like whole
documentary with his therapist and he's
like using he's those text messages are
like something like like his boundaries
or whatever you want to call them are
like nuts so he's like using all this
like therapy like honestly I think that
this is a really bad look for therapy
like I agree because this is in my
opinion like what too much therapy does
to a person like you become nuts and you
think like you can use these words like
and it's boundaries words and you speak
like therapy speak that you're right
that all of your feelings should be
validated yeah and you know what like
you shouldn't like part of being in a
relationship is compromised so like
let's say you know her being in a thong
bikini is something that makes you
uncomfortable but for her it's
liberating and it's a part of her job
like that's something in a relationship
you would compromise on but he's so up
his therapist's ass making a documentary
about it like he thinks that he's
entitled so honestly I was like damn
like there is a thing as too much
therapy Yeah a hundred percent
and it's like if he couches his qualms
in therapy language and she couches hers
in therapy then they're like they're
both right like it's like we're out
there like whose feelings are more
important when feelings are so important
it's not a good look for stats no his
therapist I um I don't I'm just learning
about this documentary now I I don't
care it was like a crazy did you watch
it no but I saw the trailer and it was
like basically the concept was like
Jonah Hill like I'm Healed
and here's a documentary on me and my
therapist who helped get me here got it
well that's even crazier now that it's
like clearly he's you know intense yeah
intense intense I wouldn't want this
wouldn't work for me but now not to make
everything about us you know we set out
many many years ago with the goal of
getting Justice for David Foster and we
did that right when did when Sarah and
Aaron Foster came on the toast we feel
as though Justice was was served now I
do feel like justice was served for
Ruthie in this situation like really
Ruthie dodged a bullet like he doesn't
seem like so pleasant to be in a
relationship with and you know there's a
cover for every pot but I don't think
that cover was worth it because Ruthie
was kind of this like independent-free
spirited girl really I don't know Ruthie
if I know Ruthie like I think I know
Ruthie or maybe she was a traditional
Queen who wanted to be you know wifed up
also from these text messages that she
shared it was very clear that he really
wanted to start a family like very yeah
and I think that's probably if you like
read between the lines probably what was
one of their biggest issues in their
relationship where it was like he would
have literally would have you know
gotten her pregnant that day she had
been ready and it's clearly like she
wasn't ready and that's not something
she wanted when he entered into a new
relationship it was the first thing we
did and so it's like
at least his actions now were like
congress with what he said that he
wanted which was just to be like a
family man yeah but
still an intense person speaking in an
annoying [__] language couldn't be me
yeah and I I hate to like doubt
someone's experience but I think we need
to be really like careful about how we
use language because I based on those
text messages he doesn't seem like an
emotionally abusive person he seems
emotionally manipulative like he seems
crazy but I think like you know we just
have to be careful about labels and
language yeah that's what we've been
saying also like everyone now if you
break up with someone they're a
narcissist like does anybody know what
the word narcissist means no let me tell
you the only person on the planet who
was allowed to call their ex and
narcissist is Ariana Maddox not the only
person on the planet but I'm saying a
recent example of like a person who
everyone was using that language for Tom
Sandoval misogynist narcissist and
there's like actual history from the
last 10 years proving that he is that
person for sure does anyone know what
narcissist means like because honestly I
don't even I don't go around slinging it
I do
I can't it's like one of those words you
can't really explain
the problem all of these big words yeah
people overuse them and abuse them and
they start yeah nothing gas like trauma
boundaries yeah no they're like it's
these therapy words that I'm telling you
this is like not a good look for therapy
yeah so I mean and and I even see it in
like not even with celebrity culture
like in day-to-day life like I'll be
talking to a girlfriend they're like he
was a narcissist I'm like
no I think people in the way that like
gaslighting became code for like someone
who just lies or somebody you disagree
with
uh narcissist now I think is code word
for someone who's just like
self-involved
no I don't I think it's just like
someone like anytime someone does
something that like you
that didn't like make you happy it's
just like a narcissist yeah you know
like narcissist is like a clinical word
no it's like someone who's like like a
serial killers or narcissists yeah it's
it's a word like sociopath like it means
something something extreme we don't
know what it means Condition it's yeah
no it's like an illness let's Google
though not even illness it's like a
personality like um disorder it yes yes
narcissistic personality disorder thank
you is a pattern of self-centered
arrogant thinking and behavior a lack of
empathy and consideration for other
people and an excessive need for
admiration
um
people also often describe people with
MPD as cocky manipulative selfish
patronizing and demanding but yeah like
that part like an ex lack of empathy and
consideration for other people it's like
if someone did something to you that
like hurt you you could say they didn't
have empathy for you and they're a
narcissist right no like yeah they're
not it's a little bit of like a jump
yeah it's a jump so that's just like
what I've noticed no you're right it's a
new buzzword like yeah that everyone's
using and it loses its meaning to
describe like their ex who behaved in a
way that like obviously made them upset
enough to break up with it it was
unfavorable that was unfavorable yeah no
it's taking the uh The Gaslight Journey
nobody like everyone was just like ass
like trauma trauma's up there yeah
trauma like trauma used to be like for
you know clinical for for like
therapists post-traumatic stress
disorder like uh you know vets
oh is there a fire in the building the
alarm's going off I feel like it's fine
like the alarm in this building is
always going off we could like just make
sure there's not yeah maybe pick your
head out in the hallway see if anybody's
running maybe smell for smoke oh yeah
I don't smell it no the alarm stopped
I'm telling you the alarm is so dramatic
like
nothing's going on like we're fine yeah
so
Jonah Hill had a really bad how about
yeah how do we feel I know that like my
take is like a hot one it's not gonna be
popular but I just like don't feel like
it's so cut and dry like this is an evil
bad man well also I feel like when
you're in a relationship with someone
you obviously text all the time and you
have like serious conversations via text
so to like selectively screenshot
certain parts of the conversation like
you're always it's always going to be at
an angle and of course those are not a
good look for Jonah and I would never be
in a relationship with that type of
person
um
but it's important to keep in mind like
what we're seeing yeah yeah and like
when you are in a relationship with
someone like you if especially he seems
like a stream of conscious text or like
yeah the craziest part to me is like 10
in a row yeah no it's a lot but like you
think it's a safe place you're talking
to your girlfriend like not like that
the whole world is going to see these
things one day so it's just kind of
but you know Jonah this is a consequence
of Normie life like a fellow celebrity
would never you know leak text messages
because they know the importance of
privacy yes and no I feel like it could
go both ways like maybe a fellow
celebrity wouldn't put a fellow
celebrity also has the platform to speak
what happened to them even if they do
like a podcast and like allude to what
happened whereas he might think that by
dating normies they don't have that sort
of reach and that no one would like
listen to them yeah
that's true
yeah I don't know I don't know and I
also don't care you know yeah
like I'm not a Jonah Hill girly like by
any means
so it's like bye you know yeah yeah it's
like that's how I feel too
this isn't like a loss for me right if
but I I also just feel like
people are
making it a little bit like more than it
is when it's like okay so he's a like a
freak I don't even know what to call him
because I'm not gonna abuse words right
right it's just like I don't want to
date him yeah right right like I
wouldn't but good luck to you yeah
there's a cover for every lid whatever
the word is true a lid for every pot
it's true
are you ready for our next story are we
talking about the devastating news about
Renee rap because no I'm not okay got it
because I'm not ready yeah no we're
keeping it
um you know high level
there's an announcement happening
what'd you say
I didn't get one word no me neither like
but I feel it didn't sound urgent yeah
she said thank you why don't you go down
and and text text what you text us be
like hey girlie is there a fire yeah
we'll keep doing the show yeah yeah I
don't think there's a fire no do I just
text us
okay moving on moving on so much drama
back in studio so much drama now to make
like the fire about us but it's almost
like kind of like they don't want us to
talk about Jonah Hill oh my God it's
conspiracy
literally
um this weekend big news out of Kansas
City Taylor Swift took her talents to
Kansas City and it was a big speak now
weekend a couple of highlights Long Live
is now added to the set list pray for
counselor snitch she premiered a music
video for one of our songs called I can
see you with Joey King Presley cash and
Taylor Lautner who joined Taylor on
stage they all did of course but I don't
care about the other ones who joined
Taylor on stage and did a flip okay
let's start from the beginning Long Live
being added to the setlist it's unclear
if that was like a Kansas City weekend
thing or if it's going to be permanent
moving forward I have to imagine it's
permanent
um there's a lot of like rage from the
fandom that like all you know all
there's been like 30 shows already like
what about us she's played to over 2
million people like what about the two
million people I get I get the symbolism
of the song and how she wanted to wait
till she owned it to sing it like I
totally get it but like am I annoyed
yeah it's like I went to three shows and
I didn't hear it once moving on
um but I think it's better than her
playing it as a surprise song for just
one people right one people yes
[Laughter]
uh next the music video the music video
was very good I like that song I can see
you and it was obviously just like all
about getting her music back there was
like a bunch of hidden codes it was like
a fun thing it wasn't that serious I
really liked it and I loved how she
brought back a Taylor Lautner who's kind
of a a hero of the speak narrower now
era because he's really I believe the
only person
that Taylor has written a song about
where she's literally apologizing to
them she's not like you know demanding
an apology she's apologizing and I think
you know the way him and Taylor's
relationship has aged has been really
good for for him he kind of has like a
reputation of being a p-job and you know
not to make everything about me but you
know Ben and I are actually really good
friends with him and his wife and
they're delightful and he really is like
this lovely guy he would validate that
he's a p John I can co-sign that he's
like an incredibly kind nice person and
definitely treated Taylor with the
utmost respect and so to see them like
all these years later reunite and like
this really precious way where like
they're he's married you know he's
totally moved on she's had just getting
out of a six-year relationship like it's
not like a it's not like a will they or
won't they thing it's like a true
friendship out of like you know love and
respect and they have this history
together and it was really very sweet
and full circle and you know a fun fact
about Taylor Lautner um and I don't even
know if he did it for Twilight but they
showcased it in Twilight I think it was
like just a passion of his
um to get into martial arts so a lot of
the stunts he did in Twilight were all
him the stunts he did in the music video
were you know martial artsy were all him
and I think he just wanted to honor that
when he got out on stage and he said he
didn't even plan to do it but there's
kind of a long walk from they opened
these doors for all the guests for Joey
King and Presley and and Taylor she was
in the mean music video along with Joey
King as beyond that I'm not sure
um that's what I got because I looked at
her Instagram and said I'm in the mean
music video yeah so they opened the
doors when Taylor announced them and
there's probably like a like a thousand
foot walk I would guess like a thousand
feet we all clear there's no fire okay
great there's like a a big long walk and
so it's kind of awkward like it happens
a lot on talk shows whereas people are
like hi oh like they don't know what to
do so Taylor did a flip and I respected
the hell out of it no I could see how
that could happen like you walk out
there's 70 000 people there yeah do a
flip do a flip they landed hyped up I
mean what if he didn't no I know I'm
thinking about that I think he's been
doing martial arts for like 20 years it
doesn't matter what if the stage like he
did a cartwheel first into his flip like
what if it was slippery he put his hand
down slip but it's it's Taylor staging
it's perfect you know I'm just saying no
it was it was a brave thing to do it
could have been catastrophic it could
have been catastrophic also like to do
backflips and such like not on like you
know a foam board always freaks me out
like you could snap your neck
no that's that worries me less he could
have like stumbled and embarrassed
himself yeah but he didn't but instead
he crushed it crushed it it was a really
full circle like sweet amazing moment
for the fandom honestly he's so cute and
sweet like it was fabulous it was really
cute so um
speak now is here speak now is here I've
listened to the Vault songs a bunch more
times a clear front runner for me is
when Emma falls in love
um close second is electric touch but I
still I haven't like lived with them
long enough to even remotely like have
like a ranking or anything got it I was
giving you my hot take on the bald sauce
yesterday Jackie actually had a really
she's gonna hate me today like with all
my tape just do it okay no you're what
you're about to say is not negative it's
actually like an interesting point okay
because I'm like so like I said on
Friday like we were we've all been in
competition about who speak now meant
the most for so like I love this album
the songs are amazing my issue with the
Vault songs I felt this way about
Fearless too I don't know if I was able
to figure out why I felt this way and
articulate it or and if I did if I ever
said on the show but I do feel this way
about speak now I did not feel this way
about red which I think will make sense
but it's just like
I'm not like loving hearing like
mature Taylor sing these songs that she
wrote when she was more immature and or
no speak now it's not 15. she's probably
like seven years she's like immature you
know love songs right which at the time
with the speak now songs when I listened
to them like those were
felt like mature feelings for me I feel
like the music that she writes now like
on midnights is just so like ever more
it's like so elevated it's so elevated
there's such big thoughts and so to
listen to new music that's written by
like a teenager sung by an older person
and I'm supposed to relate to it now it
just like doesn't really do it for me
and you know what that's totally fair
yeah it's fine no like
it's fine that's not like a hot take
like that makes sense but I didn't feel
that way about red because
um first of all the adult songs were
amazing the ball songs were amazing I
feel like the most memorable Vault song
is really the All Too Well 10 minute
version Oh I was good I don't count that
as an adult I know but like that's what
I what I think about what we got from
Red 10 minute version Oh I think of I
bet you think about me and messaging
battle is all I can do yeah like I never
added a message in a bottle to my liked
oh by the way you're so wrong for that
no I know I'm just saying like it's a
Carly Rae Jepsen like [__] popping pop
songs no I know I know and they're good
songs and and I have I hope everyone
enjoys them I'm just saying like for me
I can't like get back into that
headspace like she's writing Mastermind
now I understand yeah no I know what
you're saying yeah that's fair so um
that's not a hot take it's really not
yeah so that's why like the Vault songs
don't necessarily do it for me
um but I'm loving you know re-entering
the speak now Eric so they say that when
Emma falls in love is about Emma Stone
and Andrew Garfield look what do you
think about that I didn't even really
like like I know that they're like been
friendly over the years but I don't
think they were so close and when Taylor
played it in Kansas City she played it
for one of the surprise songs she said I
wrote this song about one of my best
friends I could see them being best
friends they're so like they never get
like photographed together
don't you think that's crazy
and do you have you listened to when
Emma falls in love like half of it but I
was shaving my legs and the water was
really loud so I couldn't really hear it
okay tell me if anyone else feels this
way like I keep singing when Emma falls
in love and then accidentally singing
jump and fall
oh I do that all the time when Emma
falls in love I love each Freckle on
your face oh I do that all the time with
Taylor songs it's really confusing me
but I believe when Emma falls in love
has um sampled Drops of Jupiter which
was a famous song of Taylor's in the
speak now era she covered it oh um thank
you I'm so glad I brought this up I had
something I wanted to bring up after you
kind of like tried to drag my stanhood
on the toast on Friday okay
um you were like you only became
activated like whenever no I remember I
couldn't believe I forgot this I
remember like how and why I became the
biggest Taylor Swift fan
I believe the year what year did speak
now come out 2010. the year was 2010. I
was forced to run an errand for our
mother to go to Radio Shack which was
one of my least favorite [__] errands
to run and I was like pissed about it
young Sheldon would not be happy we need
to talk about that okay
I went to Radio Shack I remember I was
like I think our house phone was like
broke and I took buy a new house when I
was like so pissed that this was my
problem and when I was checking out I
like got you know her credit card which
was like such a great feeling and right
by the register they were selling a
speak now concert DVD and I bought it
um just to like kind of Stick it to mom
being like oh you made me go I'm buying
this 10 DVD
um when I tell you I still have that DVD
I must have watched it no less than 500
times I didn't know that it activated a
a level of psychoticness in me and
that's where I can't believe I've ever
had to bring that up it's such an
important pertinent piece of information
I know that I remember that it played on
Loop in our house like in every room
everyone loved it
oh my gosh I always loved it it was my
thing it stayed in my room it's in my
house still I literally have the DVD at
my house
don't even try okay but that is I bought
it that is not incongruous to what I was
saying like you've always been a Swifty
and a fan for music
uh seriously like you're right your
takes today are horrible if you just
shut up no I didn't say they were bad I
didn't know they were hot a few years
ago you became like but even when you
were like on the watching the DVD you
weren't like on Tumblr with the other no
but that doesn't make no but now you've
become one of those fans no I haven't
I'm very level-headed
there is a big group of us a
level-headed swifties We Exist we just
don't get attention because we're not
crazy
okay
young Sheldon oh my God okay Jackie
finally started young Sheldon like I
finished it over the weekend me and Ben
actually restarted it because Jackie was
starting it so I want to go on the
journey with you tell me your thoughts
on everything it's literally the best to
come on TV yes
he's so precious and it's what's so
funny is like so often like my heart
just like goes out to him I feel like so
sorry for him because he's obviously
like different very different and
isolate like he doesn't have you know
peers yep he's Peerless he finds peers
don't worry but he doesn't give a [__]
like even when he finally gets like or
something happens his dad is like proud
of him he's like thanks Dad like he's
not like waiting around for his dad to
be proud of him no not at all he's
buried because that brings in the game
ball and he's like it's dirty yeah like
he's not like sitting there waiting for
his dad to like notice him like he's
very fulfilled in his own interior life
so it's like you don't really need to
feel sorry for him let me tell you
what's so great about the show because
like the first few seasons the kid is so
cute who plays young Sheldon like it's
really all about Sheldon but they're
very smart that like he won't be like
that tiny forever and if you know the
character Sheldon from The Big Bang
Theory he's I literally he's moronic
he's so annoying he's so rude he's so
self-righteous so he obviously has to
become that young Sheldon he has to
become big Sheldon so in the later
Seasons he becomes insufferable and like
rude and condescending but
while you're watching precious Sheldon
you don't realize the show is making you
fall in love with every other character
in the show so that by the time Sheldon
becomes like the insufferable person
that he is you don't even care he's not
even barely like in the show anymore the
other characters you tune in for them
for Georgie for Connie for George senior
like that's the beauty of the show well
I can't wait and last night the episode
that I watched Elon was in it yeah he
stole Sheldon's Journal I know and stole
the idea it was so funny I know like I
knew you were gonna die I knew you were
gonna love the show I'm so happy it's
perfect better as show don't you does he
come back again
actually I've been watching it like
maybe two to three episodes at a time
like I don't have these like Zach and I
watch it together at night before we go
to sleep so it's like not that much time
we're not like binging it yeah we're
just like enjoying it what episode did
you watch last night
um so he is like the NASA episode where
he's like has to prove this guy wrong
and the football like the football
episode where he's like helping his
grandma's statistics so good yeah I love
the show it's literally the best show
it's really really good and really sweet
precious precious precious
are you ready for our next story no
no you're not is it our next story
that's brought to you by stamps.com
Perhaps it is when every person moment
and penny counts in your business you
can't afford to take any of them for
granted stamps.com gets it because for
the last 25 years they've been helping
businesses Like Yours save time and
money you can focus on your business
knowingstamps.com has all your postage
needs covered with premium discounts and
great rates so the samsung.com is a post
office in your office but stamps.com all
you need is a computer and a printer
they'll send you a free scale even so
you'll have everything you need to get
started if you need a package picked up
you can easily schedule it through
stamps.com on the dashboard if you sell
products online stamps.com seamlessly
connects with every major Marketplace
and shopping cart
excuse me they also offer premium
discounts because running a business is
not cheap especially when it comes to
fulfilling orders from your customers
luckily stamps.com has huge carrier
discounts up to 84 off USPS and UPS
rates plus stamps.com automatically
tells you your cheapest and fastest
shipping options they've been your
postage partner for the last 25 years
for 25 years stamps.com has been an
indispensable resource for over a
million businesses you get access to
USPS and UPS services that you need
right from your computer anytime day or
night there's no lines there's no
traffic and there's no waiting so set
your business up for Success when you
get started with stamps.com today
stamps.com has just been like literally
saving lives ours included like it's so
convenient it's so easy it's really a
great way to save money and also like
not have to you know walk to the post
office multiple times a day sign up with
promo code toast for a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a free digital scale
there are no long-term commitments or
contracts required just go to stamps.com
Click the microphone at the top of the
home page and enter code toast today's
episode is also brought to you by
bowling Branch bowling branch makes the
softest most luxurious sheets without
any toxins or harsh chemicals they use
the finest 100 organic cotton that's
traceable from Family Farm to your
family home and they have a natural
unmatched softness and that gets softer
with every wash we are bowling Branch
girlies we have been for years we've
been telling you about it and every time
one of you guys finally listens to us
you're like oh my God I wish I got
bowling Branch sooner well here is the
sign you could possibly need need a
bedroom refresh are you moving you just
want new sheets because your new your
old ones aren't cutting it bowl and
branch is the place to go your bedding
shouldn't be any different
from anything else in your house the
best of the best so start investing in
your best sleep with bowling Branch they
feel buttery and breathable on night one
and they get softer and softer for years
to come they're made with they're made
to last with the rarest 100 organic
cotton bowl and bread sheets are an
upgrade that you'll never regret bowling
Branch signature hem sheets which is
what Jackie and I have is their best
seller and for it's for a reason they
get softer with every wash they're made
with the highest quality 100 organic
cotton threads on Earth they're loved by
millions of sleepers they have over 11
000 reviews and they're so luxurious
they've even been beloved by four U.S
presidents so bowling Branch sheets come
in 10 different versatile colors and
sizes from Twin up to California King
they're made without toxins they're free
from synthetic pesticides formaldehyde
and other harsh chemicals on they offer
a 30 night worry-free guarantee with
free shipping and Returns on all U.S
orders so sleep better at night with
bowl and Branch sheets for a limited
time you can get early access to their
annual summer event use code toast to
get 20 off today at bowlingbridge.com
that's bowling branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast exclusions apply Seaside for
details take advantage they don't have a
ton of sales but their summer event that
they do every year is a great time to
stock up so code toast will get you 20
off today at bowlingbranch.com thank you
Claudia yeah well um our next story
Renee Rapp is leading sex lives of
college girls in season three Layton
Murray is leaving Essex College Renee
rap will not be returning as a series
regular to the max comedy variety has
learned Renee who plays wealthy Legacy
student Leighton will appear in a few
episodes of season three as a recurring
character but will then depart the show
she posted a statement you know with
love and support on her Instagram didn't
say much Mindy Kaling posted and being
like we can't wait to come see you on
tour I think it's very clear that she's
choosing um her music career over her
acting career and she's kind of putting
all of her eggs in that basket she's had
a lot of success thus far she released
an EP this year that like really went
viral on Tick Tock she went on tour I
think the tour had sold out it was a
small tour but it's like clearly she's
she's kind of on like that Tate McRae
pipeline you know from Tick Tock even
though she's like an accomplished singer
she's from Broadway the movement behind
like her pop music comes from tick tock
um now this is devastating I absolutely
love sex lives of college girls I think
it's one of the best shows on TV right
now
um Leighton was one of my favorite
they're all great I actually really like
all of them I don't have a favorite and
I don't think her leaving will like be
the end of the show because I do think
like Kimberly and Bella like all the
girls like they're good enough like that
I and I think they'll probably replace
her with a new roommate
um but this is devastating I don't think
it's the end of the show but it's a very
brave choice you know this is a very
popular show
um it's very much you know in the
Zeitgeist I think it's one of the number
one shows on HBO Max excuse me Max
um and so this is a brave choice to kind
of leave at the height you know I think
a lot of people are comparing it to
rajeshin Paul who left Bridgerton at the
height or
um
who else left at the height of like
their show
like some people it worked out for them
and some people it didn't you know yeah
and it's also like a little early in the
show like I I do think that if not done
correctly the show will suffer if they
don't they obviously are gonna have a
new roommate because you know the sweet
sleeps four right and they'll bring in
someone and that person will make or
break like if the show can still be good
they can't be like an exact replacement
for like leighton's character but they
have to balance
the four yeah I do think like I have a
lot of faith in Mindy Kaley I have faith
too I don't think that this means the
end and I agree like it really is
um a cast of of equals and yeah like I I
wouldn't even say leighton's like my I
love her I don't think she's my favorite
Kimberly is my favorite Kimberly's my
favorite so like I I could make this
work yeah but it just has to be done
well and I do have faith that they will
do it well me too
um but it I think it's kind of crazy
because I feel like sex lives of college
girls will go down as like for for I
mean I think we might be like a little
older in the demographic who watches it
but for like how we watched like girls
or like sex in the city like I think
it's one of those shows you know for
women characters but it's one of those
shows that like shapes a generation and
it's only in season two and it's so
popular I really I think this is a
really big mistake on Renee raps part I
agree that I think it's a mistake but I
also I know that I enjoy the show and I
know the toasters like we're always
talking about it but as far as like
actual popularity like yes I it how many
viewers does it I don't it's enormously
popular
you want me to look it up yeah I'm
curious it's it's huge
is it it always just felt like it feels
like our show but it's not everyone
watches it okay
it's the best show on television yeah
I hate when you go to work this happens
to me all the time this is why I don't
when you go to look for TV ratings on
Google literally Google will give you
like Google users rated to show three
sir what the [__] do I care no how many
people [__] watch it
period question mark
like I don't know how to I can never I
know that's why this conversation is a
moot point oh and just like that in sex
lives of college girls bring big numbers
for HBO Max according to tvinsider.com
Great TV Insider tell us more looking
for numbers
right after it and just like that Mindy
Kaling sex lives of college girls whose
final episode aired on December 9th
their ever growing viewership increased
76 since its Premiere
um it doesn't help me and then
right after that they're saying was
succession
so they're saying sex lives of college
girls is bigger than succession okay
that makes me feel good but also like as
we've stated succession isn't as big as
it felt but I'm glad that sex lives with
college girls is bigger no it's huge and
I think every season that it comes out
like so much of the content goes viral
that like like they said 76 in the first
year like I think it will be like one of
the biggest shows of like not like of
people who are currently in college like
I love it but I think it's it's intended
for like slightly younger audience
um and I think it'll be one of those
shows like how we all like think back on
girls like even though like we all roll
our eyes at it now like at the time oh
my God girls was like everything yeah
the only thing is I feel like there are
so many shows now and they all like
exist in like a six-week span that no
one show can be really like Eclipse you
know I think about like the summary term
pretty like there are so many there are
all those like Netflix shows with kid
like they're all and they're all really
good and they all capture the time but
like it's almost as if because there's
so much content and like platforms that
you can do one can't stand out one can't
like dominate that's 100 true but I'm
telling you if there was one it's sex
lives with college girls like it's that
works that works for me it's the best
show like the way I cherish every
episode that comes out I'm like I don't
want to finish and so I'm upset I'm
upset I'm mad and I don't know if this
is the right career move like there have
been times where people have like left
Ensemble things to do their own and it's
worked out for them hello Harry Styles
you know
um but it's uh it's a toss-up and it's a
brave choice and I'm not sure a little
early definitely it's only been two
seasons of the show yeah
I guess there can only be Four Seasons
no but it's not the whole school yeah
you're right you're right it's like a
semester there could be a yeah yeah
okay well we shall see what happens I
think I I wish her the best I love her
music but I think this is a mistake
yeah
are you ready for our next story I guess
Kim Kardashian brought the drama in a
purple Dolce dress to the Dolce Gabbana
Alta Moda show in Italy on Saturday
obviously a lot of people there's two
big conversations happening one it's
giving speak now yep two quarters
Courtney is somewhere seething yeah I
don't know why Courtney just doesn't go
to these things you know she always was
used to go to the show with Travis but
now because Kim goes she doesn't want to
go
I don't think it's that I feel like
there's probably a legit reason why she
didn't go but she didn't go to Kim's
show and honestly if she did I think she
like it would have been better for
everyone I get why she didn't go to
kimcho she was pissed yeah I know I know
but like she should have gone to this
yeah maybe like she I mean she's
pregnant so maybe she doesn't want to
travel she's also didn't go to Italy
with her family this year yet like she
was true La Dolce Vita so maybe she's
not traveling like I don't think it's
she didn't go
to not support okay and also this isn't
Kim this show has nothing to do with Kim
Kim just attended and looked sick right
and looked like Taylor Swift on the
cover of her new speak now Taylor's
version and everyone was quaking yeah
and honestly as you and I were saying
like Kim really needed this after
Michael rubin's party yeah well the
thing is is what I really like and I
think we haven't even spoken about this
nearly enough as we should is the
partnership with Dolce and Gabbana Ben
was like are you sure it's not Dulce and
Gabbana I'm like get out of here smelly
what are you talking about
um something that I think provides a lot
of value to Kim in the partnership with
Dolce Gabbana is like Dolce Gabbana is
so like classically feminine and like
they don't do like new modern fashion
you know they don't have any spandex in
their line you know and she would never
be seen wearing a gown like this it's so
traditional it's so Elizabeth Taylor
like diamonds in a big gown it's classic
and she doesn't dress like this and to
see her like this is so she looks like
the old Kim like she looks amazing I've
had enough of the spandex no I agree and
this is just like look if she dressed
like this all the time you know what we
would get what kind of looks we would
get yeah and I know that she's always
trying to be like ahead of her time and
I get that there's like a purpose but I
just like beautiful things and this is
beautiful yeah I agree so thank you
Dolce and I mean thank you Courtney
literally literally yeah because she
wasn't doing this before but I think it
all works I love this look also I feel
like a lot of the other Dolce looks that
she's worn she's like made them her own
Kimmy them yeah because it was Kim X
Dulce yeah even when she went for
Courtney's wedding like she was she
found a spandex outfit from Dolce like
she was wearing Kim Dolce period this is
just like totally Dolce Italian La Dolce
Vita fabulous fabulous glamorous
feminine like there's not a shred of
spandex stylish that she loves like and
it's nice to change things up especially
when she flopped so hard last weekend
yeah she looks amazing like she looks
amazing I loved all the content from
this Dolce Gabbana weekend
um they had fabulous people there and
everybody looked fabulous and I enjoyed
consuming the content so thank you Dolce
why do you keep saying it like that
because Ben told you to yeah he must be
right Ben's right about everything right
Ben oh wow
wow Olivia Copeland Christian McCaffrey
were [__] fabulous obsessed [__]
gorgeous yeah like it was just a
beautiful weekend with beautiful people
yeah and I loved it sat next to Rosie
Huntington Whiteley another fabulous gal
and Anita and Chris was there and Chris
was there Chris looked great yeah it's
so funny how like the event had nothing
to do with Kim but like the only thing I
saw was like Kim I was seeing the event
throughout the weekend and I was like oh
this is nice and I was also like
wondering if Kim was gonna go but then
she was like posting some from some farm
and I was like oh I guess she's not
living a little Dolce Vita right boom
beat us she doll shade it was fabulous
and it really was giving speak now like
I think people are always like jumping
to like and like they're wrong but this
really like it's almost identical yeah
and they said speak now what do you
think the Kardashian girlies are gonna
do when the Everest tour rolls into we
talked about this what do we say I my
theory is that Chloe's gonna take all
the girls got it they have to like be a
fan right the kids yeah because they're
fans of everything I mean they love Katy
Perry like yeah just wait till they hear
about Taylor Swift yeah definitely I
don't think him's gonna go but I do
think like Auntie Chloe could take that
but do you think they're gonna they're
not gonna go in like the celebrity tent
right no I think they'll have a box
right because they're besties with uh
these Ops yeah and they own that Arena
or whatever or the team yeah whatever
they get access they get access yeah
okay interesting that's my thought and
that was my thought do you have any I
don't know like so looking forward to
seeing what happens because the level of
celebrities not level even the
randomness of celebrities that have been
going like Jennifer Garner was in Kansas
City Tony Collette like the most random
people
um because everybody either they
themselves or their kids our fans and
Taylor's been so welcoming it's not even
like a super super A-list people it's
like if you're even if you've been on TV
she'll welcome you so I just I'm curious
yeah I'm so looking forward they'll go
out of town
but I feel like that's kind of extreme
to just like avoid a concert it's also
like kind of obvious you know it depends
where they go
no I think
like I think you're or maybe like they
go with one of their friends moms you
know then we wouldn't ever know if they
went like maybe Tracy takes her kid and
North you know
but then we wouldn't know we're like Nat
and Olivia you know but then we wouldn't
know why they would post on Instagram
um
I don't know
I'm done like I just to me like that's
why I'm really I'm looking forward to
August is that when the shows are yeah
they're kind of soon wow we'll know soon
enough I know our fifth and final story
is some good news it's fine I think
Kim's old siac and Corey beer man call
off their divorce two months after
filing they're giving it another shot
Kim and Croy Kim filed to call off her
divorce from Kroy court documents
obtained by Page Six Show Kim submitted
the request Friday at noon asking that
to be dismissed without prejudice he
filed his own dismissal a couple of
hours after her
like I I want to feel relieved I know
but too much has happened in the two
months but I'm suspicious
and this is so I don't know how you are
on the track for one of the worst
divorces like literally the allegations
being hurled and then how it just is
nothing like I understand how people can
reconcile for sure it happens all the
time but I don't know how you go from
how they were so far down like the worst
possible path drugs gambling stealing
fraud how you go from that to
reconciliation like I I genuinely like I
don't understand maybe you just get to
such a bad place and you're like this is
not what I want for my life like I want
what I had like I guess I just I'm
having a hard time visualizing it yeah
no a lot there's a lot out there that
now it's like can't be unset the news
isn't as
peachy as it would have been if
it came like right after they announced
their divorce uh but I do think
ultimately like this is best who needs
like if you can make it work make it
work I do believe that Kim is um on the
upcoming season of Atlanta so maybe this
will be covered in some sort of way yeah
I don't know to what capacity I just
could see like you know two people like
reaching like really rock bottom yeah
and then being like why are we doing
this like we have kids like we loved
each other once like we can do it again
we can do it I don't want to live like
this and I don't want to spend the next
few years in court and like and I do
have love for you like I don't know why
can't we get that back that's it was
beautiful
it's possible
I'm just like could never be me you said
even like that's what you [__] said
about me like I'll literally never talk
to you again it's true and it will ruin
your life like they really they went so
low but you never like get into such a
terrible fight with someone like you
think like you'll never yeah ever be
able to forgive them or look at them and
then like something just lifts yeah
years later not a week
two months in total no but we were
reporting on like until yeah it started
two months ago but there were things
happening as of two weeks ago yeah
no I'm something ain't right I don't
know I don't like I'm I want to be
overjoyed you know how much I'm rooting
for these two but now I'm just
suspicious yeah
yeah I hope that it is what it I hope it
does today yeah hope it's all good but
yeah no it's it would it's most likely
not but what would be bad like what
would they be hiding or you know
I don't know confusing in the meantime
I'll take the W how about that
but um I got one eye open when I'm
sleeping as you should
all right those were the past five and
you needed to know absolutely every
single one of them each one more
important than the next true
um and that's our show that is our show
tomorrow you know depending on just
Jackie's overall being we plan to be
back in studio we do plan to be in
studio tomorrow but if she's not feeling
well we'll be home yeah
and I'll be in studio tomorrow night for
Talk Shop live yes Eastern Time selling
sign books pre-order your copy of the
camera and accounts are at the camper in
the counselor.com if you want to sign
copy tune in tomorrow night yeah it's
gonna be really fun
shall we we shall thank you so much for
listening to The Chosen Linda Morning
Show retail the festival so you need to
know everybody YouTubers videos
of an amazing day we'll see you tomorrow
for home day goodbye love you bye